ce matin c'est stéphane le foll bonjour
stéphane le foll merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous depuis votre vie maire
socialiste du mans stéphane le foll on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
monsieur le foll et stéphane on va
commencer bien sûr avec la conférence de
presse de jean castex a attendu ce soir
à 18 heures un nouveau point sur
l'épidémie mais aussi un nouveau point
sur le confinement qu'est ce que vous
attendez cet après midi du premier
ministre je vais vous dire doit pas
répondre à votre question mais c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut sortir c'est à
dire entre deux défenses thomas ferrando
presse que ce soit vous me demandez
qu'est ce que j'attends chaque membre
est comme toute vie demain on appliquera
au mieux et bruit des prismes hamada et
un soir et je bois qu'on est arrivé
[Musique]
j'aime les moches l'avenir que pour
gérer maintenant deuxième vague est bon
mais la deuxième vague d'avoir organisé
autrement
moi je retrouve la mise en place d'une
conférence sanitaire dans laquelle sera
pas dictée bien sûr en berne a reconnu m
les associations et lui connaît
parfaitement les métropoles urbaines
le mje il arf il puis les deux le
commission sociale du parlement à savoir
à l'assemblée nationale j'ai un
gouvernement avec ses ex policiers et un
enfant
le santé publique qu'ils soient là on
explique hans expliquent et qu'on trouve
des solutions sortie soit on se tait
rhdp parce que je crois qu'on est arrivé
au bout
système des gaullistes ou non sur
l'épousé du premier ministre sans
constat qu'on me dise je préfère qu'on
change de l'état
messieurs les folles on vous sent en
effet un petit peu désabusé et j'entends
dans vos propos une forme de remise en
cause du du conseil de défense au sein
duquel les décisions du président de la
république sont prises est ce que vous
estimez de la même manière que jean luc
mélenchon qu'on n'assiste là à une forme
de dérive autoritaire du pouvoir
non je moi je peux qualifier dérive
autoritaire dans l'autorité dans
l'autoritarisme que chacun peut toujours
faire des commentaires
moi ce que je dis c'est que là on est
arrivé à un moment je vous donne un
exemple pourquoi je vous dis que je sais
que la semaine dernière dans la presse
locale
et d'annoncer l'arrivée des tests
antigénique et une pharmacie après
l'autorisation et l'information
nécessaire et des visites et donc à
vannes article et c'était une commune
qui était juste un autre pan est sentie
gênée en 15 minutes le champ où
l'information est venue à la rescousse
des suspects possiblement visite des
mensonges rencontre s'il avait prévenu
le maire même pas leurs effets
d'ailleurs qu' il y avait trop bu mais
que maintenant et dsk une assemblée non
mais si on vous comprend bien on à jean
castex qui parle beaucoup des
territoires qui dit qui dialogue avec
les élus locaux qui vendent ce fameux
couple maire préfet vous vous dites ça
n'existe pas dans les faits
préfet ait fait son travail le préfet
date a fait son travail mais on est si
vous voulez un peu les gouvernements
palais présidentiel et là il reste un
peu dans la bande à chaque fois jusqu'au
contact de la résistance des
informations alors je pense
et maintenant il est dedans dit m j'ai
bêtement se concertent depuis tout gosse
tâche comment alors après l'arrivée des
mis la difficulté de la chaire il n'y en
ait pas qui nécessité des mesures ont
été prises de l'art à la manière avec
deux manières l'aca festi moi ils font
quand même elle capable je m'installe
par segment il changer de méthode il
faut quand même se préparer
collectivement à la tarte
on parle tous dû à un stage aujourd'hui
où on est tous clairement qu est ce qui
va se passer on se retrouve à encore une
fois il des informations qui vont
arriver
je ne sais pas où et qui vont mettre
tout le monde au vu des joueurs changer
de méthode aujourd'hui il est dedans
semaine alors nodules ta vidéo opérant
sûrement pour que une question posée
soit mise en place une observation la
gestion de cette deuxième vague est là
messieurs le foll vous parlez de du
vaccin c'est vrai qu'il suscite beaucoup
d'espoir mais est ce que la france se
prépare suffisamment ou est ce qu'elle
est déjà en retard comme d'ailleurs le
suggère le patron du ps olivier faure
mais ça alors on peut faire les
commentaires et l avance des prix est la
constance du vaccin et impose d'aller
sur axa ap hausse ce matin et une
problème c'est que
les médias on apprend et j'ai lui-même
la légion de la commission européenne
qui baisse l'an prochain j'aurai des
batailles que les 12 possibles
takeda en fonction des besoins
rien mon sens qui va organiser tout ça
c'est encore le mythe affronter le
polémiste les routes dir un square de
république et après les haïr est
terminée
et puis nous et blida l'ogresse
d'ailleurs les pc au dernier moment d'y
associer des maires des choses on ne va
pas directement maintenant ce digne ni
de faire face qu'il faut être
responsable et nous laisse aux normes et
aux responsables d'en trouver
stéphane le foll a priori il n'y aura
pas d'annoncé de réouverture des petits
commerces ce soir c'est en tout cas ce
qu a fortement laissé entendre marc
fesneau est ce que vous le regrettez et
est ce que vous entendez le sentiment
d'injustice de la part des petits
commerçants on imagine que c'est pareil
dans votre ville du mans est ce que vous
redoutez que ça entraîne de la colère et
un mouvement type gilet jaune amer mais
attendez je pense que la colère vous
parlez des petits commerçants et moi ce
que je vois aussi c'est que de demander
des autorisations pour pouvoir faire une
heure à peine de sortie on prend l'air
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
3 quelle situation nous sommes alors il
faut limiter la circulation et les
échanges parfaitement ont pris mes
journées sur avec l'état d'urgence et
qu'il a aujourd'hui sur les privations
liberté aidez sauve nication qui sont
extrêmement lourdes alors j'ai entendu
le ministre de l'intérieur qui eux dit
qu'il va renforcer les contrôles
enfin aujourd'hui quand vous êtes dans
un appartement et que vous voulez sortir
pour une heure il faut remplir un papier
plus personne ce que ça
à présent donc moi les petits
commerçants c'est un vrai sujet la
privation de liberté qui peut être
nécessaire inde en s'adonnant en poudre
et après il faut consommer 10 écoles je
répète fautes qu'on puisse discuter de
la manière dont on va aborder la fin de
cette deuxième vague et la sortie la
plus rapide possible que ce confinement
c'est ça la question moi j ai demandé
j'ai envoyé ce matin sur un certain
nombre de médias et une étude américaine
qui prouverait que les bars et
restaurants sont restreints saad hariri
on le sait aussi d'autres lieux ont dû
être responsable identifié comme étant
responsable de la diffusion du virus
est-ce qu'on avoue une étude d ce qui a
été fait quelque chose permet de
clarifier les choses voyez ce matin
levée des accusations aussi en rhône
alpes et sur le niveau de diffusion du
virus dans les écoles ou discutons que
ça c'est pas le conseil scientifique
avec le conseil de défense qui a
uniquement les informations et me dit
est sur les bases series actions de
liberté stéphane le foll c'est pas rien
à ce que le gouvernement pendant va trop
loin dans ses mesures de confinement
non mais je ne dis pas qu'il va pas trop
loin ne cherchez pas plus uniquement à
critiquer le gouvernement
je vous dis simplement vous me parlez
les petits commerces jeudi mais est ce
que vous rendez compte aujourd'hui pour
sortir une heure de chez vous il faut
vous remplissiez une autorisation bon
dos qui s'est quand même pas rien mais
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y avait ça
va mais aujourd'hui je vous ai dit quand
c'est nécessaire parce que faut le faire
tomber la circulation cyrus oui mais ça
ne peut pas durer
parce que aujourd'hui la colle à colère
des petits commerçants pas être aussi
relié à un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens parce que tu ya quand même
une dimension extrêmement privative de
liberté et qu'il faut qu'on y fasse
attention et c'est tout
lourd à supporter on est justement déjà
en dissipation de difficultés dans la
vie quotidienne
autre sujet mais ce n'est moi je demande
vraiment je reviens ce que je disais il
est temps maintenant que le gouvernement
paie précisant la change de méthode ne
peut pas attendre tous les matins le
conseil de défense et le soir la
conférence est où l'allocution du
président de la république savoir ce qui
se passe bien qu'on restait stéphane le
foll passage elle est juste moins
terminer une enquête aussi sur la sarre
je vais essayer avec le docteur denis
savoir aussi comment les at war les
étoiles ceux qui ont été contaminés par
un virus
comment il imagine avoir été contaminé
au puisse voir aussi tout est venu et
comment les gens autres autre sujet qui
vous intéressera sûrement mais sur les
folles puisque vous avez été ministre de
l'agriculture c'est vrai que on a
beaucoup parlé des néonicotinoïdes cce
pesticides tueurs d'abeilles en 2016
lors du débat sur le projet de loi pour
la reconquête de la biodiversité qui
inscrivait d'ailleurs cette interdiction
des néonicotinoïdes vous aviez adressé
une lettre au député à ce moment là pour
les inciter à de ce nom ne pas se
prononcer en faveur d'une interdiction
simple et total ma question est la
suivante c'est si vous aviez été dans
l'hémicycle au mois d'octobre
est ce que vous auriez voté en faveur
d'une réintroduction de ces pesticides
alors évidemment je ne suis plus dans
l'hémicycle et jouer et garder la ligne
qu'il advienne quand l'interdiction
vous avez rappelé ma position elle était
parfaitement construite
c'était de dire vous interdisez tous les
minots négo tuerie moi quand je suis
arrivé comme ministre et chatham 3 et
les premières interdictions des néo
n'exprime c'est moi qui les ai pris et
c'est moitié et un dernier reviennent et
on écoute n'est utilisé dans l'ensemble
enrobage de semences qu'ils étaient eux
utilisés pour des blancs qui avaient des
vocations mellifères bon ensuite ça a
été interdit totalement avec chris et
j'avais prévenu dans la lettre parce que
vous
c'est pas la totalité de la lettre mais
j'avais mis un prévenu quand vous
interdisez totalement et que vous ne
construisez pas d'alternative
vous allez aboutir à utiliser tout
produit chimique qui sont pas forcément
meilleurs d'ailleurs ou alors vous allez
à lisant les rapaces qui vont vous
obliger à revenir sur la décision
j'avais pas dit autre chose que ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui et je suis d'autant
plus quand on dirait en colère par
rapport à ce sujet que la majorité
actuelle avec d'autres d'ailleurs remis
en cause ce qu'on avait voté dans la loi
d'avenir dans les certificats d'économie
de produits phytosanitaires qui visait à
obliger les vendeurs de produits chibi
offrir des alternatives à la chine et ça
ça a été annulé par la loi mais gagner
résultat quand j'entends la ministre de
l'environnement journée d'hier c'est
parce qu'on a pas d'alternative et on va
autoriser les néonicotinoïdes de manière
temporaire
je lui dis si vous n'aviez pousser et
garder les certificats d'économie d'eau
sanitaire comme je l'avais demandé à
nicolas hulot pour forcer les vendeurs
de chiny à offrir autre chose que de la
chimie on n'en serait peut être pas là
chacun a sa part de responsabilité alors
est-ce que j'aurais voté ou bah c'est
pas le sujet moi ce que je vous dis est
ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai écrit ce
que j'ai pensé ce que j'ai dit il à
dessus je ne change pas d'avis donc vous
comprenez qu'à ce moment là les
socialistes qui déposent un recours au
conseil constitutionnel vous pensez que
c'est une bonne chose
je ne sais pas ils ont déposé un recours
au conseil constitutionnel pour ou non
un bon très bien c'est pas ce sujet ça
c'est le sujet là c'est c'est les
conséquences d'un vote alors l'euro
quand c'est aussi le genre est ce que
vous pensez qu'à l'époque et je commande
je le sens dans vos propos qu' on n'a
pas suffisamment préparé la sortie des
néonicotinoïdes c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une responsabilité
demande du président hollande mais je
joue un rôle écologique et dans la loi
était fait justement c'est une
conception de modèles nouveaux prêts par
isoler la betterave en utilisant telle
et telle chimie et en disant je vais me
priver de telle ou telle molécule puis
quand vous apercevez que ça marche pas
parce que vous n'avez pas changé votre
modèle de production vous allez chercher
une autre molécule chimique
tout ça c'est une question
d'organisation là encore de concession
des itinéraires techniques
c'est ce qu'on a appelé l'agroécologie
dans la loi dernière je le rappelle
voter une large majorité large avec lui
des ide l'époque et toute la majorité
plurielle qui pouvaient exister
cette loi fixe l'agroécologie comme
objectif pour la france ont sur nous
est-ce qu'on en reparle de lui que le
gouvernement est arrivé
moi j'avais fait ce choix parce que pour
aux élites et utiliser la chimie il faut
repenser complètement les modèles de
luxe s'était agit pas uniquement en
supprimant tel et des molécules stefanov
allons bon on va parler d'un autre sujet
qui inquiète là aussi c'est la grippe
aviaire et le gouvernement qui a placé à
près de la moitié des départements
français en risque élevé est ce que là
vous pensez que le gouvernement a
suffisamment préparé une éventuelle
arrivée du virus est est ce que dans un
département comme le vôtre s'inquiète
mais s'inquiète par tous acheté la
branche de faire la mise à l'écriture de
sziget encore vis-à-vis que deux grippe
aviaire à gérer deux et avec non pas une
menace mais la diffusion de la ville
deux fois en tout grand sud ouest avec
des conséquences économiques et sociales
qui était extrêmement lourde
une première session avec la mise en
place un vide sanitaire avec mais donne
chef dictée l'objectif négocier
l'objectif y entre on a fait ce vide
sanitaire
on a remis en production tient prête à
brionne qui vient là qui arrive avec
l'autre
haruna des oiseaux migrateurs qui
peuvent être vecteurs de la grippe
aviaire et 7 2 samedi pas venir est
arrivé jia d'oiseaux migrateurs on a
pris des décisions très lourdes
encore une fois j'avais des bassins
mention est ensemble de la filière sur
les la biosécurité pour éviter
transports là aussi un virus lorsqu'il
arrive on attend des décisions sont
prises
meniri lui qui savent ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est ce que le gouvernement
suffisamment préparé les choses
vous vous devez voir ce qui se passe
dans votre département de la sarthe est
ce que vous dites on est prêt à une
éventuelle arrivée de cette grippe
aviaire
non mais madame d'abord je subis dit
soulagé bleus de l'agriculture quand
même donc je suis le président de
l'agglomération
jeudi on savait ce qui se passe vraiment
oui le département d'assas et les plus
loués donc ce serait que les risques
sont importants et dont la seule manière
d'éviter la diffusion du virus au jury
c'est un confinement
voilà dit aussi simple que ça l'ait
intervient à peu près ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure à la crise que les
mesures ont été prises ya de sa meute
ils alertent faye a lu le jeu entendu
des cas de grippe aviaire qui ont été
dotés en allemagne ailleurs oui
attention je sais ce que ça peut
représenter
on est dans une période où les
migrations des oiseaux migrateurs et
c'est le chiffre fait peur je les dis tu
oublies pas aller en finit sur un autre
si j'agis bien sûr on va parler aussi de
de la gauche et du et du et plus
largement aussi de la candidature de
jean luc mélenchon comment vous avez
accueilli cette annonce est ce que pour
vous au même titre que olivier de
olivier faure c'est à la fois pas le
moment et en plus une symbole des
ambitions égoïstes d'un aventurier
solitaire je l'avais dit l'oeil est
jaloux dans un jean luc mélenchon sera
candidat
eelv et je les dis d'ailleurs aussi la
langue en chez les écologistes lui il ya
deux candidatures qui semblait se se
profiler entre jadot et piol et on voit
bien que ces deux constructions
écologiques et que d'ores et déjà le
débat est engagé
or c'était et l'udc ne construit pas
d'accord avec l'analyse qui est faite de
parodier simplement après les gaullistes
ou de volonté solitaire d'être candidat
jean-luc mélenchon jusqu'à nouvel ordre
il a une ligne politique
alors on peut contester cette politique
et c'est ça qu'il faut faire plutôt que
simplement sur la question des personnes
que ce qui me fera ils skient souvent
paradoxal et en particulier dans le
discours d'une serveuse à sa demande le
leader de la gauche c'est de contester
l'élection présidentielle au nom de la
personnalisation et quand ils ont à
disputer des différentes candidatures
il ne parle que des personnes non
derrière jean-luc mélenchon il ya une
ligne politique ça se comprend pas qu'on
puisse par être conscient de cela
salim politique d'ailleurs qui ressemble
à celle d'arnaud est une divine alors un
peu plus gauchiste sûrement que ça un go
c'est un souverainisme créé affirme je
le dis aux français qu'il a produit six
ans suit jean luc mélenchon ou ces
souverainistes la sortie d'actrice qu'on
va vivre économique social a été aidé
lié à une crise mais à la conséquence de
veiller comme un souverainiste la tête à
la france ça sera d'y ajouter une crise
euros alors messieurs le foll messieurs
la folle j'ai bien entendu que donc vous
aviez prévu jean luc mélenchon les
candidatures à des verts alors je vais
consulter l'oracle qui vous voyaient
pour la qu'une candidature au ps
ah oui c'est à ce point là très solide
mais c'est sûr que c'est quand même
c'est quand même sacrément en béton de
en effet de ne voir aucune personnalité
émerger mais c'est pas embêtant c'est
c'est réel c'est celle
pression ou c'est la concrétisation de
la pensée politique qui doit y est qui
doit être la base de ce qui fait une
personnalité peut porter un projet
présidentiel
est ce qu'il est on sait exactement
d'ailleurs ce que pense le parti
socialiste alors on sait ce qu'il a fait
et c'est souvent d'ailleurs contesté le
le mandat d'hollande sert à tous ceux
qui ont été ministres ou pas d'ailleurs
critiqué très bien et il ya des
critiques à faire et moi je suis prêt
allez j'en ai fait et il faut les faire
quand même temps aujourd'hui où en
sommes-nous
quel jeu rangs deux exemples faut-il
défendre la croissance ou pas par
rapport aux écologistes
faut-il aussi réduire demain les
déficits budgétaires
quand on sait qu'on va arriver à 8 10%
au full tilt comme le dit jean luc
mélenchon et elle s'en parle d'un
nouveau considéré que le de stabilité
budgétaire
il faut en sortir alors que sans dire
d'ailleurs jusqu'où on va aller de paire
d'années c'est sa seule évocation et ctv
de ces questions parce qu'on va c'est
sur ces questions qu'on va se quitter
stéphane le foll merci beaucoup
dire que deux joffrin cambadélis sur ces
questions très bien merci beaucoup merci
stéphane le foll d'alors est avec nous
depuis votre ville du mans merci julien
on va regarder la une de la voix du nord
entre deux confinement à peine ouvert
ils ont baissé le rideau
c'est à la une de votre journal me
souviens pas de ce tuto club des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics d'eau
vous présente le club des territoires et
micha acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires avec la presse
quotidienne régionale et télévision
qu'elle et les ans des radios avec nous
aujourd'hui
[Musique]